color versus patients who were white and
what the differences in treatment about
were them between them just the
disclosure trained their treatment
patterns right just the disclosure just
knowing that one is susceptible so I
applaud you because the first part of
your question was what can I do about my
biases which suggest to be
self-knowledge self-awareness and having
the kind of critical thinking that will
if that study is correct will result in
you being much more vigilant about
offering care equally to patients of
color as to white patients those are the
things I can think of
hi it's just sort of a curiosity I'm
wondering if you see less less implicit
racism with Pediatrics
I would assume kids would be sort of a
great equalizer and I'm just curious at
this yeah good for you yes we do so
there's a study done out of Wayne State
Michigan yeah Michigan that is actually
a series of studies that shows a couple
of things pediatricians have lower
biases than other physicians slightly
lower biases than other physicians
foreign trained medical graduates have
lower biases than other physicians
people who grew up in the in different
countries with different sets of social
knowledge and social inputs have lower
biases there's a lot of work yet to be
done on implicit biases right I thought
that this was a conversation starter
I thought and felt strongly that this
problem is too deep too broad too wide
too important not to talk about even
given the state of the research as it is
right now we don't have a lot of
information about implicit biases beyond
black white and Latino white pairings
that's a shortcoming in the literature
we don't have a lot of information about
implicit biases and what it does beyond
the physician group with resetting with
exception of the of the one study
pertaining to students we don't know
what pas clinical pharmacists nurse
practitioners we don't know about their
biases and the influence on their
treatment if anybody's been to the
dentist and had the receptionist treat
the mug ly they don't go back right so
what about people who are administrators
in the healthcare system what influence
do their biases have so I do believe
that even though we're doing cultural
competency today even though we're
spending lots and lots of money on
making sure that people know that
differences exists we've got to go
further and deeper and do the type of
stereotype negation that changes the
habit of being implicitly biased that
changes the habit of thinking
automatically and letting your automatic
thoughts override what your preferences
are I want to close by saying that ever
since I was a little girl my mom would
have to pull me back from trying to make
justice happen when I saw that it wasn't
happening what we see in the health care
system is not just disparities that's a
sterile term it's not just automatic
it's not just ubiquitous and therefore
acceptable implicit biases are not a
given and the problem that they create
is fundamentally a problem of injustice
and these United States cannot continue
to tolerate the injustice that results
in people of color dying and living
sicker than whites just because of their
color thank you
[Music]
so just being here I've informed that
courage ever want to get a copy of just
medicine
please give miss Matthew an opportunity
to get make our way over to the signing
table which is here to my right your
left before you leave we ask that you
fill out I see some of you are these
surveys these surveys help us make the
best use possible better strongly
Shepherd Tigers should be nearby and
sensible to share with your neighbor if
you don't have to for yourself available
so please save time to put that out
please make your way over the sidewalk
thank you so much
it's got a wonderful question and I
purchased my books here or do I have a
person the books there you can get your
books sign here then please see my
friend Justin in the bookstore to repeat
the transaction to thank you so much
we want to hear from you tweet us your
feedback about the programs you see here
twitter.com slash book TV
and now I'm very pleased to introduce
tonight's speaker Adam Cohen is a New
York Times bestselling author and a
lecturer at Yale Law School he has
formerly served as a member of the New
York Times editorial board and was a
senior writer for Time magazine where he
also has a weekly la column before
entering journalism Cohen was an
education reform lawyer and was a staff
attorney for the American Civil
Liberties Union a graduate of Harvard
Law School he was president of vol 100
of the Harvard Law Review and his
previous books include nothing to fear
FDR's inner circle in the hundred days
that created modern America his latest
book imbeciles chronicles the Supreme
Court's decision in 1927 to allow
Virginia to sterilize a young woman for
eugenic reasons the New Republic calls
imbeciles an important new book that
takes us back to a rarely remembered era
of our history reminding us that Adolf
Hitler regarded American eugenic law as
an inspiration Cohen's narrative of the
legal case that enshrined these
practices as a page-turner and the story
it tells is deeply almost physically
infuriating we're very pleased to bring
the conversation to Harvard bookstore
tonight please join me in welcoming Adam
color thank you thank you very much it's
a pleasure to be here I'd like to thank
Harvard bookstore for hosting a
wonderful bookstore that I used to spend
a lot of time in when I was here in a
previous life and thank you all for
turning out including some old friends
here at a book party in New York
recently and the invitation that went
out automatically as these things are
now said to the top imbeciles book party
and some of my friends objected about
what it would mean if they attended so I
think this was also billed as imbeciles
book talk so I want to congratulate you
all for coming and not being afraid so
this feels for me like a homecoming
we're about equidistant between my
freshman dorm which is if you want two
feet that way and college newspaper a
little closer where I spent a lot of
time and it's it feels great to be back
um so in 1927 the Supreme Court was
asked to do
side a simple question should Virginia
be allowed to sterilize Carrie buck a 20
year old inmate of the state colony for
epileptics and feeble-minded who had
falsely been declared to be
feeble-minded in an 8 to 1 decision
written by justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
the court ruled that no part of the
Constitution not equal protection not
due process not the right to bodily
integrity protected carry buck from
being sterilized against her will
plenty terrible but the Court did even
more it also strongly endorsed the
eugenics movement and issued a clarion
call to the nation to sterilize more
unfit people Justice Holmes wrote that
the nation had to sterilize those who
SAP the strength of the state to prevent
our being swamped with incompetence in
words that could have been torn from the
pages of a eugenics pamphlet Holmes
declared it is better for all the world
if instead of waiting to execute
degenerate offspring for crime or let
them starve for their imbecility society
can prevent those who are manifestly
unfit from continuing their kind then
Holmes went on to include in the
decision one of the most brutal
aphorisms in American jurisprudence
Holmes the Harvard educated scion of
several of Boston's finest families said
of Kerry buck her mother and her young
daughter
three generations of imbeciles are
enough when legal scholars rank the
Supreme Court's worst decisions the
competition is considerable
there was the Dred Scott case in which
the court ruled that an enslaved man had
no right to sue in court for his freedom
there was Plessy vs. Ferguson in which
the court upheld Louisiana's law
segregating railroad cars by race and
there was Korematsu vs. the United
States in which the court upheld the
internment of japanese-americans during
World War two
there will always be differences of
opinions over which of these rulings
should be on a list of the worst
decisions and how they should be ranked
but there can be no doubt that buck V
Bell must have a prominent place in its
aftermath not only was Carrie buck
sterilized against her will but in the
end as many as 70,000 Americans were
sterilized many of the victims were like
Carrie perfectly normal both mentally
and physically and they desperately
wanted to have children
buck fie bells reach extended beyond the
United States the Nazi Party which was
on the rise in Germany used America as a
model for its own eugenic
sterilization program the Supreme
Court's ruling influenced Germany's
genetic health courts which ordered some
three hundred and seventy-five thousand
eugenic sterilization x' in fact at the
Nuremberg trials at the end of World War
two Nazis responsible for the
sterilizations cited buck vs. Bell in
their defense while many of the courts
worst decisions are now central parts of
American history buck V Bell is not well
remembered today even in law school
constitutional law courses it is rarely
discussed or mentioned only in passing
the leading American constitutional law
treatise which weighs in at over 1,700
pages devotes just half a sentence and a
footnote to the case I'd like to talk a
little bit about buck V Bell a case that
became ever more interesting the more I
learned about it and I'd like to offer a
few thoughts about why it remains
important and then I'd like to open this
up and get a conversation going
um the United States in the 1920s was
caught up in a mania the drive to use
newly discovered hereditary science to
perfect humanity modern eugenics which
had emerged in England among followers
of Charles Darwin crossed the Atlantic
and became a full-fledged intellectual
craze the United States suddenly had a
new enemy bad germ plasm and those who
carried it the unfit the genesis warns
threatened warned threatened to bring
down not only the nation but the whole
human race America's leading citizens
led the charge to save humanity john d
rockefeller jr. Alexander Graham Bell
and former President Theodore Roosevelt
who took to the pages of a national
magazine to insist that the unfit must
be forbidden to leave offspring behind
them prominent scientists form eugenic
organizations with names like the
committee to study and to report on the
best practical means of cutting off the
defective gene plasm of in the American
population in big cities and small towns
eugenics was the intellectual issue of
the day Women's Clubs invited lectures
to speak on the subject of arranging
eugenic marriages clergymen competed in
national eugenic sermon contests
organized on topics like religion and
eugenics does the church have any
responsibility for improving the human
stock best-selling books and magazines
explain the concept of quote race
betterment to an eager public the
inspiring the wonderful message of the
new
ready cosmopolitan explained was that it
offered the promise of preventing once
and for all the birth of the diseased or
crippled or depraved conferences were
held the American Museum of Natural
History in New York hosted the second
International eugenics congress a truly
terrible gathering and the US State
Department sent out the invitations
universities were quick to embrace
eugenics and give it their intellectual
implement or eugenics was taught at over
300 universities and colleges including
right here Harvard Columbia Berkeley and
Cornell the driving force behind the
eugenics movement of the 1920s was
historians suggest the collective fears
of the anglo-saxon upper and middle
classes about a changing America record
levels of immigration were transforming
the nation's ethnic and religious makeup
and with increased industrialization and
urbanization community and family ties
were fraying these anxieties were being
redirected and expressed in the form of
fears about the unfit the eugenics
movement offered two solutions one for
the threat from without and one for the
danger from within the answer to the
foreign threat was new immigration laws
to limit the number of Italians Jews and
other non Northern Europeans admitted to
the country the U Genesis claimed that
these groups had inordinately high
levels of physical and mental hereditary
defects that were degrading America's
gene pool among other things they
claimed based on intelligence testing
that between 40 and 50 percent of Jewish
immigrants arriving at Ellis Island were
mentally defective Congress held
hearings at which new Genesis explained
various nationalities biological
deficiencies acting on these eugenic
arguments Congress adopted the
Immigration Act of 1924 which invited in
more immigrants from Northern Europe and
closed the door to Southern and Eastern
Europeans the harm that this immigration
law did was immense most of all to the
Jews of Eastern Europe who would soon be
trying to flee Nazi Germany's genocide
or regime and would find the door shut
we now know that in the 1940s otto frank
wrote repeatedly and desperately for
visas for his wife and his daughters
Margot and Anne but he was turned down
because of the 1924 act so when we think
about Anne Frank it's true that she died
in a concentration camp because the
Nazis thought Jews were
inferior but she also died there because
the US Congress believed the same thing
in addition to immigration limits to
deal with the ex the external threat the
eugenicist work to address the internal
threat through a series of laws designed
to prevent the quote unfit from
reproducing they began in Connecticut in
1895 with laws prohibiting various kinds
of people deemed to be hereditarily
unworthy from marrying but New Genesis
worried that the unfit would then just
reproduce out of wedlock next they
promoted segregation as they called it
placing quote defective people in state
institutions during their reproductive
years to prevent them from passing their
law their flaws on to a new generation
but holding that many people in
institutions for so long was expensive
finally the eugenicist turned to
sterilization which was completely
effective and could be carried out on a
mass scale inexpensively starting with
Indiana in 1907 states adopted
legislation authorizing forced
sterilization of people judged to have
hereditary defects they called for
sterilizing anyone with defective traits
such as epilepsy criminality alcoholism
or dependency in other word for poverty
their greatest target however was the
feeble-minded a loose tech designation
that included people who were mentally
challenged women considered to be
excessively interested in sex and
various other categories of individuals
who offended the middle class
sensibilities of judges and social
workers fears of the tide of feeble
mindedness as it was called rose to
panic levels a leading psychologist
published an influential study arguing
that feeble-mindedness quote underlies
all of our social problems including
crime poverty and prostitution the
eugenic sterilization movements most
prominent leader insisted that to remove
the quote worthless 1/10 of the nation
15 million people would have to go under
the knife Virginia was late to adopt
eugenic sterilization it waited until
1920 for 17 years after Indiana what put
it in the center of the legal battle was
that Virginia hospitals decided they
didn't want to sterilize anyone until
their law was tested in the courts all
the way up to the Supreme Court to
accomplish this they decided to create a
test case it was Kerry bucks misfortune
to be at the wrong place at the wrong
time
Carrie's story is a sad one and an
infuriating one she was being raised in
poverty by a single mother and was taken
in by a foster family there was nothing
wrong with her physically or mentally
but she was raped by a nephew of her
foster mother when she became pregnant
out of wedlock the family had her
declared epileptic and feeble-minded and
shipped her off to the state colony for
epileptics and feeble-minded she arrived
just when the colony superintendent was
looking for an inmate to put at the
center of his test case Carrie had just
the personal attributes the genisis were
looking for she had been designated
feeble-minded and as a woman who had
given birth out of wedlock at 17 she
embodied the eugenic nightmare of feeble
minded people reproducing rapidly and
flooding the nation with so-called
defectives Carrie also had the sort of
family the eugenicist wanted her mother
was also a colony inmate who had been
designated feeble-minded although likely
she was not and she had other relatives
in the institution which could help the
state establish a hereditary pattern
there was more to Carrie story but no
one was interested in hearing it she was
not in fact feeble-minded despite the
state's unreliable intelligence testing
her school records which the colony was
not interested in revealed her to be of
perfectly normal intelligence and she
was not epileptic she had never had a
seizure and never would the colony held
a hearing on whether Carrie should be
sterilized a proceeding heavily stacked
against her rule that it should that she
should be and it was this order that was
appealed through the Virginia courts all
the way up to the US Supreme Court
nations rely on civil society public and
private institutions devoted to higher
values to promote truth and justice and
keep them on the right path four of the
nation's most respected professions were
involved in Carrie bucks case medicine
academia law and the judiciary in the
form of four powerful men each of them
was on the wrong side dr. Albert pretty
was the man who selected Carrie to be
the first person operated on under
Virginia's law he was a physician who
served as superintendent of the colony
for epileptics and feeble-minded he'd
also been one of the main people who
lobbied the legislature to pass the
eugenic sterilization law in his
campaign for eugenic sterilization dr.
pretty had much of the medical
profession behind him across the country
doctors took a leading role in promoting
eugenics and eugenic sterilization
medical journals were filled with
polemical articles advocating
sterilization with titles like Reis
suicide for social parasites Harry
Laughlin the head of the eugenics Record
Office in Long Island New York was the
scientist who gave his expert opinion
that the Virginia law should be upheld
and that Kerry should be sterilized
Laughlin was the most prominent advocate
for eugenic sterilization and he had
drafted the model law of the States were
using to drop their own laws
Laughlin who had a doctorate in biology
from Princeton and had been a professor
was also to great extent representative
of his academic peers many of the
nation's most prominent academic
scientists strongly supported eugenics
and eugenic sterilization the center of
this academic support through genex I'm
sorry to report was right here at
Harvard University President Charles
William Elliott addressed a 1912 meeting
of the Harvard Club of San Francisco
advocating for racial purity he wrote an
article supporting eugenic sterilization
and he served as vice-president of the
first international eugenics Congress in
London in 1912 and to leading Harvard
Jeanette geneticists were among the
nation's most influential scientific
advocates for eugenics finally or
thirdly Aubrey strode was a lawyer who
drafted the Virginia sterilization law
and he went on to defended in the courts
all the way up to the United States
Supreme Court strokes profession lawyers
also offered strong support for eugenics
among the influential voices praising
Connecticut's first-in-the-nation
eugenics law was the president of the
American Bar Association who declared
eugenic marriage laws necessary to
protect quote future generations from
the evil operation of the laws of ready
finally it was the great Oliver Wendell
Holmes who had the last word on carries
fate and who with his broadside against
society's imbeciles leant his enormous
intellectual prestige to the
sterilization cause Holmes was not a man
who easily found enjoyment but he would
later say that upholding Virginia's
eugenic sterilization law and carry
sterilization had given him real
pleasure of all the professions it was
the judiciary's role that was the most
disappointing it is worth noting that
the Supreme Court that heard Cary bucks
case had some of the leading lights of
American law on it the Chief Justice was
William Howard Taft who had already
served as president it included Louis
Brandeis the great progressive who was
no
the people's attorney before joining the
court and of course there was Holmes
former harvard law professor and perhaps
the most respected justice in Supreme
Court history when the case reached
these nine great men they got the facts
wrong the legal analysis they applied
was shoddy and the vote was not close
those who airbrush buck V Bell from
history would likely offer a simple
explanation that is that it is an
anomaly the Supreme Court they would say
was briefly caught up in eugenics but it
was a short-lived one-time mistake and
the issues it raises are ones the
nation's long the nation long ago put
behind it but this argument has serious
flaws first unlike so many of the courts
worst rulings buck V Bell has never been
overruled in a 1942 case the Court
struck down in Oklahoma law providing
for sterilization of certain criminals
but it did so on very narrow grounds the
court expressly chose not to overturn or
even limit buck V Bell and after the
ruling states continued to sterilize
thousands of people as recently as 2001
a US Supreme Court of Appeals in
Missouri just one step below the Supreme
Court cited buck V Bell in ruling on the
case of a mildly [ __ ] woman ordered
by the state to be sterilized second
there's nothing outdated about the cases
subject matter as recently as 1983
Oregon's board of eugenics was still
functioning and it performed its last
sterilization in 1981 in 2014
investigative reporters discovered that
a hundred and fifty female prisoners in
California had been sterilized between
2006 and 2010 not always with the
woman's consent and other examples of
eugenic sterilization done unofficially
emerge with disturbing regularity more
broadly the 21st century is being hailed
as the century of biology an era that
experts say will be defined by the new
biology of genomic research including a
vastly deeper understanding of the
genetic blueprint for individual humans
scientists are now able to edit human
embryos paving the way for what the
press has dubbed designer babies this
will make it far easier for the state to
impose eugenics if it chooses a final
reason buck V Bell remains critically
important is that its deepest subject is
a timeless one power and how those who
have it use it against those
do not carry was at the bottom of the
nation's economic and social hierarchies
in her plea to the court she was asking
for protection from powerful people and
institutions that threatened to do her
harm throughout the history of American
law that has not been a good position to
be in the code of hammurabi the ancient
Babylonian law that French
archaeologists uncovered in 1902
included two hundred eighty two distinct
laws covering such modern seeming
doctrines as liability for negligent
acts and the presumption of innocence
the code also had an eloquent statement
of its own purpose to bring about the
rule of righteousness in the land so
that the strong should not harm the weak
that simple ideal remains more than
three thousand five hundred years later
the laws highest calling but it is a
vision that the American legal system
has all too often failed to live up to
Dred Scott Homer Plessy Fred Korematsu
they were all weaker parties unjustly
harmed by stronger ones who came to the
Supreme Court seeking justice in each
case the court sided with the strong in
fact American laws tendency to favor the
powerful could be said to be one of its
defining features in the end this is the
most troubling thing about buck V Bell
it presented the court with a stark
choice between Hammurabi's ideal and its
precise opposite the ancient principle
of justice teaches that the purpose of
law is to ensure that the strong do not
harm the weak the eugenicist and the
state of Virginia insisted that the
strong must harm the weak and that it
was the law's duty to help faced with
this decision the Supreme Court did not
merely side with the strong it
enthusiastically urged them on insist it
insisted it be better for all the world
if Society strongest members simply
finished off people like Kerry once and
for all even the ancient Babylonians
understood that helping the strong to
obliterate the weak is the very opposite
of justice
[Applause]
so if you'd like to take questions
comments well listening to what you said
it's really quite interesting
unfortunately for me it made me feel
uncomfortable about it because I'd been
an obstetrician for 40 years and I've
done abortions and one of the main
reasons we had done abortions was to
eradicate trisomy 21 [ __ ] ism and
it sounds as if we applied the principle
over the week shouldn't be hurt badly by
the strong I feel uncomfortable about
the what I might have done I think it's
a I think it's very interesting point um
and you know obviously there's a lot of
nuance here right and you could say one
level of eugenics that is certainly very
disturbing is the kind that Carrie buck
experienced where the state imposed it
on her as a potential parent the state
made the decision that she could not
reproduce and that is invasive at a very
high level it sounds like maybe you're
talking about a different case where the
parent has made the decision well it's a
very common thing I mean in the sense
that eugenics in termination of
pregnancies is practiced all this
violence no but with the consent of the
parent right and if the consent of the
parent but not know the fetus right no I
so I'm just distinguishing between those
two cases but I think you're right we
this still puts us in an area of
eugenics that some people may not feel
comfortable with and I wonder if other
people have have thoughts about it
yeah there's been a number of different
journalists recently who have been
talking about the rise of American
authoritarianism and I'm just wondering
how you kind of viewed this conversation
within the current movement of Donald
Trump and the direction towards
basically people feeling socially
threatened in as far as the mores of our
society and the movement in that area
and how that makes them react in a very
protectionist and overbearingly
authoritarian way towards those who are
not in power I think it's a great point
and we could definitely draw a lot of
parallels between the 1920s and today I
think I alluded to some of them that it
was a time of great transition also a
time of very high levels of immigration
the eugenicist were very scared of the
new immigrants who often were of a
different religion and look different
and a lot of the people who were most
active in the eugenic movement were the
the middle class the upper class white
Protestants who felt that their world
was slipping away from them and I think
you're right that you can see eugenics
as a form of authoritarianism another
parallel is I didn't go into it and
suchlike but in the book I talk a lot
about Oliver Wendell Holmes and the
degree to which he had a very
authoritarian upbringing and then
judicial philosophy he was a member of
the Boston Brahmin class here in Boston
and in fact his father dr. Oliver
Wendell Holmes senior who was the Dean
of Harvard Medical School coined that
phrase Boston Brahmin and if you think
about it that was very intentionally
saying that the quote old and and and
higher families of Boston were a caste
of their own like the Brahmin caste in
India and of course under Hinduism
they're the the Brahmins were thought to
be endowed by God so that was the way in
which Holmes was brought up he was
brought up to think that his people and
the Oliver is the Wendell's and the
homes were all Boston Brahmin Brahmin
families homes his first relative
ancestor attended Harvard in the 1600s
he was raised to believe that his people
were better
and that he was at the top of a
hierarchy and when Carrie buck comes to
the Supreme Court and she's from the
lowest social class in the south the
lowest white social class poor white you
know sometimes it's called trash but you
know obviously that's not an accepted
way to refer them but that low social
economic class of whites
that's who carry bucks people are and
when Holmes looks at that he sees the
very bottom of the hierarchy and he
thinks it should be obliterated so
that's another form of authoritarianism
but I think that you're right it's all
about power and control I think we see
more of it when people are threatened
and I think there's a reason the 1920s
speak to you know 2016 having some
states like North Carolina done
reparations yes absolutely yes laws have
been repealed and there have been
reparations it's just the Supreme Court
hasn't said that this holding which says
that the state has the power to
sterilize people for eugenic reasons and
that that doesn't present constitutional
problems as long as there's a due
process hearing and the state has you
know a legitimate reason to do it that
legal authority is still there so the
concern would be what if you know and
who knows what direction our country is
going into with the next president and
the next Congress if we get to a point
in a few years where either Congress or
the states begin to think about eugenics
the the default law from the Supreme
Court is still buck vs. Bell authorizing
it so that's the concern at the time of
these events the culture was saturated
with eugenics and with eugenicist
however when the Supreme Court makes
rulings today of course as we know with
citizens united and other rulings
there's a lot of reaction from the pop
from the population from the press was
there any reaction to this ruling when
Oliver Wendell Holmes made it there was
and you know you're right to say that
eugenics permeated the culture and you
know the reaction was largely positive
and as I said I mean so true you know
thought leaders as the president of
Harvard University was saying that
eugenics was a good thing Theodore
Roosevelt was saying that eugenics was a
good thing and the press was in that
as well so you know it was interesting
to read articles in the New York Times
before 1927 just you know with happy
reports about eugenic activities and is
integrate this new eugenic group has you
know risen up and is counseling people
on who to marry and teaching about
eugenics the press coverage was very
positive leading up to buck V Bell and
then the reaction afterward that wasn't
largely positive there were some
editorials and articles that were more
skeptical but overwhelmingly positive
interestingly the one group that was
opposed to eugenics all the way through
was the Catholic Church and they are
really in many ways the heroes of this
story when legislators met to consider
eugenic sterilization laws and I think
professors would be very trouble to
realize that the the sort of people who
are going to lobby for it were literally
the League of Women Voters was a very
big supporter and the people that
opposed it were often priests and nuns
and people active in the Catholic Church
and it was for a couple of reasons one
is the concern about reproduction and
just as many Catholics you know as
Catholics oppose abortion they were
concerned about that but also the
Catholic view was that people should be
evaluated on their soul on on their
spirit and the Catholic Church wasn't
comfortable with this eugenic movement
that said we're gonna look at all these
individual traits and decide whether
people are you know fit or not fit
worthy or not worthy so those were the
you know it was the Catholic
publications that also spoke out against
the ruling when it came down so you know
I think we have to credit the role of
the church there as being right on
something when the rest of the country
was was wrong
family in terms of what for comment and
the question you mentioned the Catholic
Church but as far as me
eugenics could be looked at in terms of
what happened in terms in during slavery
with Catholic Church from running
slavery because blacks had no souls
right we could also look at gobino in
France as one concession from the
fathers of the eugenics movement that
led to the United States back to Germany
and then back to the US again we could
look at what happened to Porto Rican
women were sterilized because of
immigration in 1960s the Tuskegee
experiments and so forth recent case
Haitian immigrants the chromed camp in
Miami were a man who breasts and women
could that were produced because once
you have a child a child born in the
u.s. automatically get citizenship so my
question is in terms of almost every
society has a form of Technology of
control and then the political economy
of civilization so to what extent I mean
asthma has the whole sort of moral
fabric of law and so far is concerned up
to what extent do we simply allow this
technology of control for the sake of
security and the various name no I think
that's a very very good point if you
allow me I want to say a bit about race
which I hadn't said yet um you're
absolutely right that in more recent
years eugenics has been used a lot
against african-americans and Latinos
and others but what was really so
perverse about eugenics akari bucks time
is some people you know are surprised to
learn the carry buck was white and you
know the reason she was being sterilized
was in Virginia at the time that the
very same day that Virginia adopted its
eugenic sterilization law it adopted a
second law which raised the penalties
for interval interracial marriage
interracial sex and adopted the one drop
of blood rule to really put a strong
wall between black and white races and
the you Genesis had actually
they were so racist that they had given
up on the black race they did not think
that it was worth trying to uplift the
black race they did not think that was
possible so at that time the dranks
movement was all about lifting up the
white race and also making sure that the
black race did not intermingle with it
so it was a level of racist that was so
extreme that they weren't even focusing
on sterilizing black people because they
thought there was no point and it was
people like Carrie buck from the lower
echelon of the white race and they were
really troubled about because they
wanted to lift up the white race and
they saw Carrie's class as the the white
people who are bringing it down so
interesting I think question might
partially really radical questions I
think I'm curious to understand on what
basis did these individuals at the time
single out certain groups for example
Jewish people or Italian immigrants
people from southern European countries
was it data that they were looking at
patterns behavior I think social
patterns I think were just trying to
understand no it's a great question and
I think there's a bit of a chicken and
egg thing here that I think that you
know a lot of these Janice did not like
these groups and then create a data to
show that they were inferior I mean
there was a real visceral just hatred of
you know of Jews and Italians and Asians
and there was a guy named Madison grant
it was a very popular writer at the time
he wrote a book that was a best-seller
called the passing of a great race which
actually anticipated a lot of Nazi ideas
about Arianism and the way Madison Grant
who was an upper-class New Yorker who
went to Columbia Law School and was on
the board of the Museum of Natural
History the way he spoke about the
Polish Jews that were walking down the
street in New York and in their Polish
Jewish clothing and they were trying to
they were gonna marry American women it
would there was so much hatred that I
think that they created data then to
show that these groups were inferior so
that was the racial thing but it's also
very interesting how they chose the
individual groups of
you know regular old stock Americans who
should be sterilized and there were
these categories the disabled the Deaf
the blind and and it was a guy named
Harry Laughlin who's one of the real
villains of my book who ran the eugenics
Record Office who drew up a lot of the
categories drew up the model statute
that many states used to draw up their
own laws and one interesting aspect of
this is he included on his list of the
people who should not be allowed to
reproduce because they were unworthy
epileptics and it turns out Harry
Laughlin was epileptic and it's unclear
exactly when he knew that he was
epileptic he and his wife never had
children
but reading that one does wonder you
know so much of hatred starts in self
hatred was he so driven to eugenics in
part because he felt that he was
unworthy and and even when he had his
first seizures and everyone knew he was
epileptic in a certain point his wife
wouldn't let him drive anymore
he never argued to remove epileptics
from the list of people unworthy to
reproduce so there's just a lot mixed up
in this bag yeah the Darwin have any
role yes so the man who invented
eugenics who coined the term from the
two Greek words for good and birth
Francis Galton was a half cousin of
Darwin's and he was really thinking in
the moment right after Darwin was coming
up with his theories of evolution and
gaulden talked about how we can see how
nature works itself out through survival
of the fittest and and and that natural
process but Dalton argued that what his
half cousin was writing about how Krane
naturally the genesis could speed up and
do more humanely rather than you know
let everyone fight it out over years and
years and years yeah do the right
choosing and sort of you know design the
the fittest would would survive but you
know Darwin himself was not a genesis
and he wrote some actually rather
eloquent passages where he said that we
could choose the people who we think are
the
kissed and the most unworthy to live but
if we did that and we obliterated them
we would also be obliterating our own
humanity
so it's really interesting that Darwin
was a great enough man that he
understood that this is not how his idea
should be used
I wonder if you predict the future a
little bit in terms of genetics and non
like the science of genetics and
non-invasive prenatal testing and you
know if you if you have any sense of
what laws might be passed and also the
coming together of possibly strange
bedfellows in terms of you know like
liberal disability rights activists and
then conservatives who may be
anti-abortion in all cases so if you can
just talk about that yeah sure it's a
great question and there are so many
aspects to it I won't be able to do it
justice but one thing a lot of people
are focusing on right now is that the
news emerged quite recently that in
China they have succeeded in editing the
human embryo right so that is the first
creation of what they call designer
babies where they can go in and actually
edit out some of the genes rearrange
them and create a baby that has been
genetically designed and those changes
will then be carried on to future
generations so there's a big big
discussion going on internationally now
about whether this should be allowed and
a lot of people are saying you know dr.
Frankenstein and these are changes that
will forever change humanity but this is
gonna happen and in England they just
approved a researcher there to do
editing of a human embryo so then we
have the question you know how do we
feel about this does this feel like
Harry buck and I feel you know it's
interesting when there was a hearing
recently in Washington about what to do
ethically about editing of human genomes
one of the people who testified was a
mother whose baby had died at the age of
six days from a genetically carried
disease and she was weeping and she said
you know just friggin do it allow this
because if she had
in able to edit out the genes from her
baby her baby would have lived and in
this discussion you now see that some of
the people who are most in favor of
allowing the human embryos to be edited
are people who themselves carry these
genetic markers so there's a scientist
in Washington whose mother you know
contracted a you know a terrible genetic
disease and went mad and he may have
that same disease he would like his
children not to have it so he's saying
we should allow this so it becomes an
interesting twist where it's actually
the quote week the people who are
genetically you know unfit who are
saying let us use this you know somewhat
eugenic procedure to make ourselves
stronger and make the next generation
stronger so um I actually think that in
many ways you know we may want to flip
some of our thinking about eugenics and
see that when we can start editing
things maybe it will be a way to
actually help the quote weak rather than
to oppress them so I think that's one of
many issues that's gonna be out there
yeah oh oh yeah so um the one in
Virginia was just outside Lynchburg
Virginia they believe back then and
putting epileptics and feeble-minded
people out in the country because they
thought that working in the fields and
getting fresh air would help them to be
cured although no one was ever cured and
this colony system was you know there
were other colonies throughout the
country it was it was a you know one of
these waves of reform it was thought to
be a good thing but you know people like
Kerry buck and her mother were sent
there for you know possibly for life
Carrie buck they let her leave the
colony after she was sterilized because
the thinking was she was no longer a
threat to humanity she wasn't gonna
reproduce Carrie's mother lived her
whole life in this colony and it's um
you know so these were you know sad
places where people were trapped they
called them patients but they were
inmates yeah
I know we've heard about prisons where
they tested medication on people and and
the inmates were not aware that this was
being done and it wasn't done their
consent how much of a voice did she have
in these proceedings I mean was she
completely informed of what was going on
and did she have a lawyer who was able
to argue in her in her behalf I mean the
whole thing is so said and you know it's
interesting cuz a reporter in Virginia
asked me today if you could talk to
Kerry buck what would you ask her and I
it was this very thing I said I wish I
knew and every stage in the process what
she knew we know that at her her
sterilization hearing that was held at
the colony she was represented by a
guardian because the law required that
but we don't know what she knew the
guardian wasn't doing much to protect
her she was very quickly ordered to be
sterilized there's one poignant line the
transcript exists and you can read all
the arguments there's one poignant line
where this augury strobe the lawyer
who's trying to sterilize her Turner at
the end and says you know does she have
anything to say and she says you know
that she trusts for people it's not
clear who her people are is there a
person The Guardian that is actually
working for the people trying to
sterilize her then when they actually go
up further in the court system the
Guardian gets her a lawyer because
that's required under the the statute
well the lawyer that they get her had
been the chairman of the board of the
colony he was friends with all the
lawyers on the other side and he wanted
her sterilized and he wrote some
terrible briefs which do you know
they're much shorter than the briefs for
the other side they leave out a lot of
important cases and you'll be reading
them you realize wow this last page and
a half really that's all reason she
should be sterilized you know so this is
what she had and you know I think at
some point you know with the going to
the Supreme Court she did realize what
was happened to the more really the more
tragic stories her sister Doris who was
her younger sister also in the colony
for epileptics and feeble-minded after
Kerry Bucky sterilised after the 1927
ruling Doris is sterilized right after
and I she's not told that what is done
to her they they tell her that she's
having a pinned ectomy or something like
that and many years later when Kerry
buck and and her sister
are located by by the the then head of
the colony many many years later in the
70s whose you know a good guy doesn't
doesn't agree what was on the 20s she
first finds out what was done to her and
she and her husband who were told the
news began weeping and they say you know
we spent our whole lives trying to get
pregnant and you know we go to the
doctor and they mentioned you know the
doctor mentioned that Doris had a scar
and you know she thought was an
appendectomy um so she learned as an old
woman what had been done to her and this
was not uncommon but you know
unfortunately because we don't really
have oral histories and journals we
don't know who found out when but many
many women were never told you know and
maybe died not knowing what the state
had done to them that's very sad yeah so
the culture of Medicine until relatively
recently was that doctors told patients
what to do on patients complied with the
doctor's orders so when did inform
consent become something in the practice
of medicine that the patients were
supposed to can understand what was
being done to them and consent to it you
know it was just starting around this
era before you know while while buck V
Bell is working its way through the
system and there was a case in New York
State where the Court of Appeals the
highest court in New York ruled very
strongly that patients had a right to be
informed and that operating on them
without getting their consent was almost
a form of assault so it was just
beginning to happen and there was a
little concern about that they were
worried that you know that could if that
you know doctrine began to spread more
broadly it could be an imposition but it
was really after after about the bell
that it became you know much more common
because you're right I mean if that had
been a robust to doctrine at the time
certainly it was being you know floated
right and left by the Genesis by eugenic
sterilization
yeah how did they manage shop
sterilization failures feelings failures
it's a significant percentage when
you're dealing with that larger
population you're gonna have failures
yeah I have not heard of any examples of
that I mean I'm sure was going on you
know they had all kinds of nefarious
ways of dealing with everything you know
what what happened to carry his baby
right they you know Carrie is pregnant
when she's ordered to be you know sent
to the Conley for epileptics and
feeble-minded you know her her foster
family just wants her to go doctor
pretty says you know we don't accept any
pregnant women we don't accept any
children so actually you know they yet
put her in with some other family until
she gives birth and then there's a
question about what to do with her baby
well lo and behold they decide to give
it to the foster family who raised her
baby as their own and then they don't
let Carrie buck come back and join them
later um so um you know I think babies
were being passed around and you know
all kinds of you know things were worked
out but I'm sure it was all done in a
terrible way for the individuals
involved yeah so the both was 8 to 1 on
the court what was the dissent so yes
great question um there was no dissent
but the the the one justice who voted
against was the one Catholic on the
court and the most conservative member
of the court and there been some
Catholic you know law journals that have
written about you know the the silence
of the dissent what would he have said
what was and and it's hard to know he
was very cranky justice he sometimes he
just objected to government activities
of various kinds there were a lot of
cases where he just didn't like the
government mucking people's lives but he
was also a very religious Catholic and
the thought is that he probably objected
on moral ground spiritual grounds but
just didn't say but we really wonder
what all these justices were thinking
and you know for me one of the big
questions was what was Louis Brandeis
thinking right I mean this is you know
he was known as the people's attorney
when he practiced law right around here
he was the great champion of the
dispossessed and he just signs on right
so
early on in this process I was very
excited to learn that a law professor
just written a 900-page biography of
Louis Brandeis and I ordered it because
I wanted to see what someone who had
looked at his entire life said and once
again we see the theme buck V Bell was
mentioned in a footnote in that in that
book there was so much about his
involvement in international Zionism his
childhood in Louisville and all that and
then footnote saying of course he was in
the majority in buck V Bell as far as I
could tell you know Brandeis had said in
an interview at one point that sometimes
he just voted with the majority to kind
of you know be convivial you know so-so
and and the Chief Justice at the time
Taft was very big on building he liked
to have unanimity or close to unanimity
so the dynamic may have been that
Brandeis you know just kind of let Taft
twist his arm but it's just amazing to
me that no one's really explained that
you know so there are a lot of you know
silences in this case which you know
maybe will never be filled in carry buck
sterilization and the 1947 willow book
mental institution in Staten Island
which was the biggest state-run mental
institution in the United States which
closed in 1980 87 and you said I think I
believe you said the 1981 with elastic
civilization right and they closed in
1987 does your book make that connection
it doesn't it just kind of um it doesn't
get that far into the future but you
know the Willowbrook case you know is
something that you know I'm from New
York and it's something we all yeah okay
great so you know that we all wrestle
with this because what was going on in
Willowbrook you know when it was open
felt like the 1920s the way in which the
inmates were you know horribly
mistreated and shut away and and so
forth but and the ACLU
you know
to its credit you know stop that but the
critique now is that no other system was
put in place what we have now in New
York is we don't have Willowbrook but
you know do we have a humane system you
know for taking care of folks you know I
think that's a national problem but but
I don't and I guess in part because I
wasn't aware that you know sterilization
occurred there but you know the the
larger problem of how we deal with
people who are you know developmentally
disabled in every way is is just huge
and I think you know not enough
attention is given to it as a policy
matter not if attention is given to it
as you know writers and readers I think
we just we we should be learning and
thinking more about it - Kerry's
daughter and whether she ever found out
about her mother well you know you know
sometimes when I talk to people about
this story they're like oh you know what
what's the happy part of it and I say
like they're really there's there are no
heroes and there's no happy part of it
so that's a good lead-in to my answer to
your question here which is that Vivian
Bach died at the age of of six of
something like measles and so she never
learned any of this but she did have a
little bit of a school record at the
time and right before the initial trial
these horrible eugenicist who were
putting together the case sent an expert
from the eugenics Record Office to
examine this then infant and he was able
to swear that she was mentally defective
because compared to the other baby that
she was next to she seemed to smile less
or react differently so so that was
enough to say that you know and then
Holmes turns it into three generations
of imbeciles
so she was recorded as being you know
imbecilic by the Supreme Court in fact
she was you know a very bright and you
know a perfectly normal child and you
know another the you know hundreds of
villains in my book the foster mother
who takes you know who throws carryout
gets her committed because she's been
raped by her nephew then takes her baby
when they go to talk to her after
the baby has died you know she does say
there was nothing wrong with Vivian you
know she was she was fine so yeah it
just sadness every direction you look
including that one language I know that
there are some writers and poets in here
you're using the word gene-editing I
mean of course it sounds beautiful right
we all would have to have editors to
make something to know beautiful what if
we had used the term gene manipulation
gene hacking or gene splicing what sort
of the outcomes of the way in which
we're thinking about gene editing be the
same I think it's a great question and
you know this is very much a live issue
right now so we're gonna have to decide
what word to use and you're right people
using the word editing but maybe we
should push back against that or maybe
we shouldn't and maybe we should say
that if you want your genes edited so
that your child doesn't inherit some bad
trade in your own genes maybe it is like
editing but if I could just since we're
talk about language one other way
language really figures in this is this
word imbeciles and three generations of
imbeciles are enough you know there are
a million things wrong with this
decision the fact the facts are all
wrong it's barbaric it ignores the law
everything else but one rather pedantic
point but that bothers me is that there
were actually three very definite
categories of mental defect back then
very precise idiots were at the bottom
then imbeciles were in the middle and
morons were at the top and these were
registered I found a pamphlet from the
US Department of Labor I think that had
a nice little chart these were
well-known categories Carrie buck and
her mother you know who were probably
just perfectly normal had been labeled
morons when they got to the colony for a
plug because in feeble-minded you know
it's not not a great category but it is
one notch above imbeciles so in addition
to everything else Oliver Wendell Holmes
does he he did motes them in its
decision he calls them imbeciles which
they you know the record made clear no
they were you know in Kerry's case
mid-level [ __ ] and
her mother's case a low-level [ __ ] but
they were not imbeciles so um you know
Holmes was a great epic grandmas and a
great wordsmith and you know one reason
I use the word imbeciles for the title I
mean they're several including the
bigger question of who are the imbeciles
you know I would say not the people
being sterilized with the people doing
the sterilizing but but also it's just
such a resonant word and Holmes's choice
of it and one thing I loved my publisher
did is you know they sent me a picture
of the cover they had come up with for
the book and they've got great designers
who do this and what they did I thought
it was so brilliant was they turned the
word imbeciles you some of you may have
it and see into a dictionary definition
and they put in the syllabus syllable
ization and I thought that was so right
because it's really saying let's
interrogate the word imbeciles you know
who are the imbeciles why did Holmes
choose the word imbeciles and so that
kind of nomenclature is everywhere and
it's definitely part of Holmes's bag of
tricks and used to you know malignant
purposes yeah it's really appropriate
because of the way the the codes in the
in the genetics are they're read you
read the stream of so when you use the
word editing it works out as if it were
an editor and I might also add as a
journalist you may have a very benign
view of the word editing but any
journalist who gets edited feels that
the editor is evil and is out to crush
their soul so you may think it's a nice
thing to me editing makes my skin crawl
yeah ya know the outcome is terrible
they take that beautiful thing you wrote
and it becomes some horrible thing they
wanted you to write so I you know it's
in the by beholder I think yeah okay
yeah yeah say that parts of this
conversation reminded me about what was
done to the Aborigines in Australia
because they certainly wanted to get rid
of them but they chose a more humane way
of permitting interment
rather than incarcerated men member I
mean it's you know again you know
depressing stories you know here they
are
so yes I think one other depressing part
of this is how we see the same tropes
over and over again right we see that
the way we treated you know our African
Americans our lower caste whites very
similar to how indigenous populations
were treated other places and then of
course you know one of the horrors of
the you know many harms of the story is
seeing just how closely what we were
doing came to Nazi Germany right I mean
the Nazis very happily adopted what we
were doing because we were doing what
they were about to do we had designated
Aryans as being superior Madison grant
wrote a whole book about it we were then
you know sterilizing people something
they were happy to do so if the line
between America and Nazi Germany was as
thin as it was I think you're right
we're gonna see the same thing with
Australia we're gonna see it everywhere
because you know there are only so many
different ways that people are horrible
to other people it often falls into
certain patterns is there one word yeah
last question it would seem that Oliver
Wendell Holmes legacy has had a very
good public relations team preserving
his relatively positive a very positive
reputation whereas in addition to yarrow
a fabulous book and in the magazine
article in the current Hobbit which is
excellent they've been the life and
times of all of the wondaland 2001 and
edward black edwin black book 2003 so
it's not as if you are the first to
point out some of these